hey guys ryan right here it's
Thanksgiving so I'm on the road right
now going to be going to a dinner with
my girlfriend I basically wanted to say
thank you wanted to give my thanks my
giving this is my way of giving by my
verbal communication to you to say thank
you for being a subscriber it really
does mean a lot to me you know and we
started off the channel I had faith in
it but you know like I wasn't expecting
the growth to be at such a rapid pace
the way it is right now it's pretty
awesome like last year we ended with
like twelve hundred subscribers I think
and then now we're almost at 50,000 so
yeah I guess that means I'm the [ __ ] if
I'm basically gonna do this and thank
you guys I should thank myself too for
how awesome I really am because it just
makes sense why you'd subscribe after
you see me I'm just that good looking
and you know I'm you guys can't see it
because YouTube but you know I'm hung
like a horse so I wanted to say thank
you and so thank you guys so much for
all your support really do love you guys
not just saying that because I'm a
youtuber I'm always on the comment boxes
i'm always looking at the video manager
i'm i'm obsessed with it so thank you
guys so much and the other thing I
wanted to do was an apology I wanted to
say I'm sorry for something it's about
to get a little serious here I saw the
pan trailer in the theaters then
everyone was like asking me to do a
trailer reaction to it but i was like
thinking i can't do a trailer reaction
to it because i've already seen it I
couldn't get anyone else to do it so I
thought like I'll just have fun and joke
around the whole time give hints that
I've already seen the trailer up front
and just do a really over-the-top super
fake trailer reaction just for shits and
giggles apparently it didn't fly too
well with a lot of subscribers they
apparently didn't catch on that I was
joking around up front and saying that
it was going to be a fake trailer
reaction so yeah I'm sorry for
misguiding you guys and misleading you
but I got a lot of hatred from it and
because of that I wanted to say I'm
sorry and I after a few weeks you know
I've been thinking about it i don't i
don't think i'm going to do youtube
anymore guys I'm gonna stop doing it
it's been a serious contemplation for a
while I'm gonna go back to college no
I'm not the [ __ ] college no I'm gonna
still keep doing YouTube I was just
[ __ ] around the apology was sincere I
I thought I had a blast filming that but
I I feel bad because a lot of people
didn't catch on that I was just gonna
[ __ ] and ham it up but here's the
cool thing about it you know sometimes
you know it's a trailer reaction so so
if a reaction happens to be like a
genuinely big one people are gonna be
like oh it's fake and if it's not a big
one people like oh this is boring so I
wanted to do a mock trailer reaction so
that way you guys can see what I would
be like if I actually faked it and
clearly I'm not too good fake it so yeah
I had fun doing it you and you'd be so
just wanted to say thank you and sorry
for you know a lot of people did get a
kick out of it but for those who didn't
sorry for you guys not catching on to a
damn joke that's what I wanted to say
that's why i say i was apologetic at
first but now I'm just mad yeah happy
thanksgiving i'm ryan right tonight I'm
gonna be watching the trailer for a
movie called pan I have not seen the
trailer for this movie yet I have not
seen the trailer for this movie yet I
didn't you know like catch it in the
theaters and all bharati scene is so
this is gonna be a very genuine reaction
no none none of it is gonna be fake it's
all going to be very real very genuine
very sincere it is no [ __ ] reaction
you guys ready for this pan right I
don't know what it's about is about
frying pan is about frying pan uh-uh
Warner Brothers good company good
company hey Peter oh it's Peter Pan well
he had a mom I don't even know who Joe
Wright is but I'm [ __ ] excited I long
for the day that I can come back for you
and explain everything
yeah you were extraordinary yeah he's
going to be it's a [ __ ] nun oh he was
a rebel he was a rebel it could be
Neverland whoa what the what the [ __ ]
no no no no no horrible horrible things
are happening right now okay it's
Christopher Walken hahaha that's the
first time I'm making that joke out loud
no I'm getting lost in the music the
untold story okay cool
what look they were friends before oh
Rudy morrow i like to think sexual stuff
of her princess is that you jack me that
you Jackman what I appreciate the
compliment Bishop hahaha god oh god
funny [ __ ] it was you Jackman
oh the guy from Sean
Wow good for you Yvonne Miller a few
stories yeah shut ya should Peter it
should well that looks moving it's like
a moving imax first time i'm discovering
that wow what a trailer that was my
first time watching it